mettez moi ça
ça normalement tu sais quoi j'ai la
musique d'attentes unis
vous avez demandé
terres de fenêtre
terres de fenêtre c'est plus de 150
professionnels à votre écoute alors que
vous fenêtre soit en toute sécurité chez
vous posez
ne quittez pas un spécialiste de la snet
vous répondre
et là alors il pose une question
savez vous que grâce à la photosynthèse
[Rires]
c'est dépenser un sou avec moi non oui
moi
une fille allait demeurer en vie même
dans une fille
[Applaudissements]
m
alléchant
il
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que c'est tom cruise et
l'actrice
[Rires]
7 au 12 mai qui
fait la moto
[Rires]
dubai 25
[Musique]
c'est long
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
m
rentrée
le 15
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on était bien en mairie ce pas
oui mais non
[Rires]
monstrueux syrie
[Musique]
à
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
oui
mais maintenant ça devient maintenant de
jouer
[Applaudissements]